foreign
off queensland's Coast Annette meant to
protect swimmers and kill sharks in
snares of whale
conservationists want them taken out for
good
why don't the Nets work 40 of shocks are
caught on the inside of the Nets trying
to make their ways back out to open
water
and 90 of what's caught in the Nets is
non-target species often endangered
marine life
when turtles and dolphins are struggling
and dying in the Nets they're actually
attracting large sharks closer to shore
there's a gap of a few meters between
the surface of the water and the top of
the net to let boats pass
it also means you can swim right over
the Nets
and soak in the sharks
all the way to the beach like these
hammerheads
so the inside the sharpness I haven't
seen this before actually
people are fascinated by shark attacks
it's one of the reasons the debate has
been so contentious the campaign is safe
it's time the government starts
listening to the science
shark attack deaths are rare state
governments say thanks to the Nets
but they do happen
seven years ago a great white mauled
this surfer's thigh
it's a terrifying moment I mean it's
it's one where all of the I suppose your
worst fears are kind of coming true as a
surfer
the net
so my my thing with with Nats is I would
like to see them see them go I would
love to to make sure that we can have
people feel comfortable and safe in the
water but not at the expense of marine
life not at the expense of sharks as
well
deadly
at beaches for more than 80 years
maybe time for a new approach
Nicole Johnston Sky News Sydney